[Musique]
mais le débat sur france 24 on attend
dans un peu moins d'une heure une
allocution d' emmanuel macron à l'elysée
que vous pourrez bien sûr suivre avec
nous sur france 24 le président français
ne s'est pas encore exprimé depuis le
séisme politique provoqué par les
résultats des élections législatives
il manque 44 députés à emmanuel macron
pour atteindre le seuil de la majorité
absolue pour faire passer les réformes à
l'assemblée le chef de l'état a
rencontré depuis hier tous les
responsables politiques du palais
bourbon pour discuter il a demandé à
isabelle borne de former une majorité
d'actions alors que peut-on attendre
bien sûr de cette allocution ondes
emmanuel macron comment gouverner dans
cette situation inédite un gouvernement
d'union nationale est il possible une
coalition peut-elle être construite par
isabelle borne macron coalition
impossible on en discute avec mes
invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
à paul vannier bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
député la france insoumise 5e
circonscription du val d'oise bienvenue
à vous dans le débat en face de vos
mohamed l aquila bonjour bonsoir pardon
député modem 11e circonscription des
bouches-du-rhône bienvenue à vous avec
nous également denis baranger bonsoir
j'ai deux professeurs de droit
constitutionnel à l'université panthéon
assas auteur du que sais-je sur le droit
constitutionnel et ses opus bienvenue à
vous également en attendant julien odoul
députés à l'assemblée nationale qui
devrait j'espère nous rejoindre cette
allocution du président de la république
qu'en attendez vous mohamed l aquila
vous qui êtes député modem je commence
par vous qu'est ce que vous en attendez
il s'est pas exprimée effectivement
depuis les résultats bien évidemment les
résultats sont là les français ont
tranché et moi je prends les choses
d'une façon complètement positive c'est
qu'au niveau du modem ça fait longtemps
qu'on porte ce sujet de la
proportionnelle en compte pour que tous
les courants sont représentés mais là
c'est le peuple qui a tranché il le nous
l'a imposée finalement au législateur il
imposer cette proportionnelle donc
aujourd'hui un il part de responsabilité
des études de l'ensemble des élus il va
falloir qu'on fasse preuve
d'intelligence con moi j'appelle ça une
éthique de responsabilité
falloir effectivement qu'on ait une
éthique de comportement on l'a eue
pendant un mandat notamment sur les
derniers temps je crois que je souhaite
en tout cas pour ma part c'est qu'on
soit utile à notre pays qu'on bloque pas
des institutions on va y revenir mais
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ce qu'il
va dire la clarification peut-être de la
manière dont tout havrais ils veulent
mais on entendra tout à l'heure sur
comment il voit la situation aujourd'hui
nous avons quand même quelques crises et
on en vit encore une autre celle de
l'ukraine est toujours là il ya le
pouvoir d'achat des français qui est
important il est venu brièvement sur le
fond
sur le faux et qu'il invite bien
évidemment l'ensemble des responsables
et des députés à faire preuve de
d'intelligence et de responsabilité
c'est ce que je voulais et à leur
l'éthique de responsabilité sera pas là
ni ritualité j'attends qu'ils annoncent
le blocage des prix des produits de
première nécessité des carburants et de
l'énergie pour répondre à la situation
extrêmement grave dans laquelle un
nombre croissant de nos concitoyens se
trouve donc vous attendait une annonce
concrète il ne le fera pas il annoncera
à la place une construction politicienne
habile en apparence mais qui ne fera je
crois qu aggraver la crise
institutionnelle dont il est le
responsable et élections a très durement
de sanctionner le pouvoir ma chronique
c'est une déroute il est le responsable
du blocage de la paralysie actuelle sans
un changement complet de politique pour
répondre aux grands défis du moment la
crise humanitaire qui guette avec une
canicule qui peut revenir cet été avec
des services d'urgence qui sont
paralysés sans changement complet de
politique alors la crise ne peut que
s'exacerber et monsieur macron et vous
l'attendez en titien malheureusement
pour être à la hauteur je crois de ce
moment devenir baranger puisque vous
êtes le constitutionnaliste de ce
plateau on peut dire qu'on vit vraiment
une période inédite finalement moi mais
de là qu'il a le disais on a
l'impression que c'est la
proportionnelle en étant un scrutin
majoritaire on voit que ça compliquait
tout de même aujourd'hui pour emmanuel
macron de gouverner c'est inédit à ce
qu'il faut faire comme les allemands
c'est compliqué mais c'est pas
impossible et j'ai du mal à conques est
ce que vous en tant qu on six analystes
vous attendez de ce discours en un mot
rien parce que c'est pas mon métier
d'avoir des attentes de ce genre le
président va certainement dit comme à ce
qu'ils pensent gouverner il est dans une
situation inédite il a pas de fait
majoritaire d'une majorité absolue pour
lui il n'a pas pour autant une
cohabitation il est dans une nouvelle
situation ce que je n'arrive pas à
comprendre c'est quand on dit qu'on peut
pas gouverner la france elle est
gouvernable ça s'appelle le régime
parlementaire très simplement vous mais
c'est la quatrième république ça parce
que c'est comme ça ça qualifié la
quatrième république c'était le régime
parlementaire ça pouvait ressembler ça
peut tout à fait y ressembler en ce sens
que désormais il devra y avoir soit des
coalitions sa part une coalition ça
paraît un petit peu difficile soit des
majorités de circonstance des majorités
d'idées faudra aller pêcher je dirais
les 44 sièges qui sont nécessaires pour
arriver à la majorité absolue ce n est
en rien impossible ça n'est pas
impossible et ça n'est pas
anticonstitutionnel enfin je vois
vraiment pas pourquoi avant les deux
tours le président avait dit le problème
ce n'est pas une habituée de la 5e on
m'a dit avant les deux tours le
président avait dit nous ne sommes pas
un régime parlementaire avec le plus
grand respect si nous sommes dans un
régime parlementaire on est en train de
le démontrer il a toutes les
flexibilités les possibilités du régime
par l'homme dont celle d'un régime
présidentiel à un régime parlementaire
dont il s'était fait un régime
présidentiel c'est un régime
parlementaire dans lequel le président
et beaucoup de pouvoir j'aime patience
et ses états unis c'est tout autre chose
là on a ravagé une parlementaire dont
l'économie va être dessiné par les
personnes qui sont autour de moi par les
membres de l'assemblée nationale et par
le président ça sera une vraie première
juniaude il nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau députés à rassemblement national
merci d'être avec nous qu'attendez vous
du discours d' emmanuel macron qui donc
va avoir lieu à 20h en direct de
l'elysée malheureusement ça fait cinq
ans que je n'attends plus grand-chose
des dix ans voilà les choses ont changé
et public les choses ont changé oui mais
veulent dire dépit de l'air mais vous
savez le dernier mandat des nacres ont
été jalonnées de crise exceptionnelle et
pourtant rien n'a changé rappelez vous
on est une crise sociale et populaire
avec le gilet jaune qui aurait contraint
n'importe quel autre exécutif à des
accommodements voire à des changements
de braquet on n'a rien vu on avait vu un
pseudo lounge vous attendait une
clarification peut-être de la manière
dont il va gouverner avec justement
l'assemblée générale
lité et la responsabilité de tirer les
leçons de ce scrutin qui est un désaveu
pour lui pour sa politique les français
ils ont dit qu avec les élections
législatives on ne veut pas d'un
maquereau absolue on ne veut pas d'une
majorité en marche omnipotente on veut
de la représentativité ils ont imposé la
proportionnelle la proportionnelle qui
leur a été retiré et volets pendant des
années et d'ailleurs ça me fait rire
parce que monsieur castaner qu'il ya un
an nous disait je ne veux pas la
proportionnelle parce que je veux pas
faire entrer sans député du rnd a semblé
là les électeurs du fn ont imposés 89 de
nos parlementaires parce qu'ils veulent
de la représentativité c'est tout donc
il faut que ce constat là s'impose à lui
parce que monsieur macron encore une
fois n'est pas le dominant en france et
le peuple souverain à l' incident on va
y revenir en tout cas emmanuel macron a
reçu entre hier et aujourd'hui tous les
responsables politiques à l'assemblée
nationale résumé de cette journée avec
nicolas chamond pas
un gouvernement d'union nationale pour
une france divisée c'est ce qu'a proposé
edouard philippe après sa rencontre avec
emmanuel macron une union qui exclurait
l'extrême droite mais aussi la france
insoumise et il me paraît qu'avec le
groupe des républicains qui est le plus
grand groupe numérique dans le spectre
que je viens dessinée il pourrait
discussion pourrait s'engager et
peut-être avec le groupe et socialistes
ou avec groupes écologistes une
discussion pourrait s'engager dès
écologiste engagé dans un exécutif trans
partisan une solution proposée ce matin
à julien bayou mais rejetée par le
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts il n'y a pas de nécessité de
gouvernement d'union nationale il ya un
parlement et c'est pas ces cafés sont
très sympathiques évidemment mais c'est
pas à l'elysée qu'on doit faire la
politique c'est dans l'hémicycle même
son de cloche chez la france insoumise
qui refusent catégoriquement d'entrer
dans un tel gouvernement nous sommes
candidats a aucun arrangement a aucune
combine ou à aucune participation à un
gouvernement avec le président de la
république pour la raison que notre
diagnostic politique et je lui ai dit
c'est qu'il ya besoin d'un gouvernement
qui précisément fasse le contraire de sa
politique de celle qu'il a menée et
combattre les effets qu'elle a répandu
le camp présidentiel souhaite recréer le
gouvernement d'union nationale de 1945
au sortir de la seconde guerre mondiale
pour redresser le pays
de gaulle fait entrer dans son équipe
tous les partis politiques de l'époque
près de 80 ans plus tard la situation du
pays est difficilement comparable et
l'idée d'un gouvernement d'union semble
assez mal engagée mohamed tequila vous
qui êtes modem donc à vous faites partie
de ensemble donc de la majorité edouard
philippe a appelé à la création de cette
grande coalition l'a vu dans le sujet
pour donner une direction stable au pays
que pensez vous françois bayrou lui
évoque un gouvernement d'union nationale
mais avec qui en fait donc on exclut la
france insoumise d'un côté le
rassemblement national de l'autre moi je
suis sur cette position depuis le début
c'est à dire quand on nous avons une
très bonne idée dans l'intérêt général
et l'intérêt des français quel que soit
celui qui la porte c'est une bonne idée
il faut la creuse et forme débattre donc
jours à des monnaies nationales donc je
continue à les y pour répond tout
simplement des urgences parce qu'à une
vraie urgence et ça a été soulevée
effectivement il ya une vraie urgence
aujourd'hui et des français demandent
quoi il demande des réponses
on va avoir les réponses très vite
peut-être ce soir mais en tout cas
parler prochaine loi de finances
rectificative qu'on va avoir très vite
au jeu
siéger à la commission finances
non non c'est ça va être c'est la
semaine prochaine quoi vous avant l'été
ça va être pendant le mois de juillet il
va falloir apporte effectivement une
réponse à l'inflation une réponse au
pouvoir d'achat et ça sera très vite
donc on verra à ce moment-là si nos
chats dire aller nos adversaires
aujourd'hui d'aujourd'hui ceux qui
disent vous avez rêvé pendant cinq ans
suivront ou pas mais donc coalition
nationale sans justement le ls je parle
à ce propos et edouard philippe oui mais
quand on a entendu le président dire des
dépassement des clivages et ça allait de
chevènement jusqu'à estrosi un petit peu
ça or aujourd'hui effectivement les
extrêmes bon on verra comment ils vont
se comporter dès le projet de loi de
finances rectificative est-ce qu'ils
vont adhérer est-ce qu'ils vont
combattre et peut essayer de bloquer
comme ils l'ont fait pendant sur la
réforme de la retraite par exemple on a
vu la france est soumise bloqué avec
trente mille amendements tout le système
donc est-ce qu'ils vont avoir un
comportement responsable et moi
j'appelle bien évidemment tous les
députés à avoir ce comportement ridicule
r ils sont pas très claires sur le
gouvernement de coalition à boxer avait
donc les républicains les députés ils
sont ils sont là pour légiférer dans
l'intérêt des français avant tout
votre réaction polvani à cette idée de
gouvernement d'union nationale sans vous
en faites sont édifiées sans et rennes
et nous ne sommes pas candidats à faire
prendre nous sommes l'opposition la
première opposition avec la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale au
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron
gouvernement d'ailleurs en train de se
chercher mais non pas par posture et
parce que nos propositions sont en
rupture complète avec la politique que
depuis cinq ans monsieur mac romaine et
celle qu'il annonce nous proposons le
smic à 1500 euros je suis macron prévoit
peut-être de l'augmenter de 25 euros
nous proposons un plan de de sauvegarde
la cantine gratuite et bio pour les
enfants à l'école monsieur macron
annonce un chèque alimentaire en 2023
l'urgence elle est là il y à des
millions de personnes qui à huit
millions en france qui pour s'adresser
aux besoins de ces propositions allaient
rassurer mais il faut des propositions
temps lorsqu'on parle de coalition en
tout cas on n'y est pas non non je vous
emmerde et nous ne voulons pas
constructif avec un gouvernement qui
prépare le massacre sociale des français
la retraite à 65 ans ce sera non et nous
essaierons de la bloquer comme nous
l'avons fait de la précédente d'être n 1
de part et d'autre julien aux jo après
addition possible pas possible a priori
sans le rassemblement national sans la
france atomise déjà si vous me permettez
je vais nuancer le propos de monsieur
banier parce que ce gouvernement dont il
a qu'il accuse de tous les maux il a été
mis en place parce que monsieur
mélenchon a appelé à voter pour monsieur
macro donc quand on voit la france
insoumise qui aujourd'hui essaye
d'endosser la tunique de l'opposant en
chef tout ça évidemment et de
l'escroquerie est ensuite concernant
l'arrêté concernant l'arithmétique
masculin chevallier vous savez compter
comme par exemple avec métier comme
hiver l'opposition à l'assemblée
nationale c'est le groupe duras nacion
je rappelle que nul ps est une collation
de coalition de quatre partis voilà donc
il ya une réalité qui s'impose le
premier vote opposition c o leur avis
sur à une coalition donc sans vous
c'était la première idée edouard
philippe mais la coalition ne sont que
six appels en marche en faites pas je
veux dire il n'y a aucune nouveauté pour
avoir une majorité qualifiée
mais c'est à voir évidemment l'accord
d'armistice kvm sur la cre ont depuis
2010 est en essayant de faire venir à
lui tous les mondialistes de gauche et
opportuniste de droite etc qui aurait
vendu père et mère pour un maroquin mais
très clairement tout ça c'est de la
vieille politique c'est de la politique
joli trait aux oreilles ça serait quoi
ça serait se mettre d'accord par exemple
sur certains textes mais la vraie
politique déjà c'est écouter le peuple
c'est lui rendre la parole et nous
appelons déjà des réformes démocratiques
le référendum 17e' citoyenne la
proportionnelle que finalement les
français ont imposé avec ces
législatives prochaines et intégrale à
toutes les élections et vie des mesures
sociales d'urgence la baisse des taxes
de 100 produits de nécessité qu'une tva
à taux zéro voilà c'est un plongeur
n'est pas du tout dans le programme
d'ailleurs de la majorité ah bah ça
s'est su très vite mais malheureusement
pardon je vous évite tout simplement en
tant que député puisque aujourd'hui vous
êtes député vous n'êtes plus sur le
programme présidentiel a analysé tout le
texte qui va être proposé dans la loi de
finances rectificative amendement par
amendement c'est ce que nous fait venir
discuter et ça sera des amendements qui
peuvent être effectivement
de l'ensemble des députés mes chers
collègues utilisent ils étaient dans le
sens de l'intérêt général aux bulls vont
dans le sens de l'amélioration du
quotidien des français nous n'avons
qu'une seule boussole c'est l'intérêt
des français si vous n'êtes pas où nous
allons d'un vote favorable du
rassemblement national sur certains
textes année vous allez avoir la liberté
de vote du député donc qu'ils s'assoient
du rassemblement national de la france
est soumise aux autres ils voteront avec
six estiment qu'il va dans le bon sens
fait je l'espère bon on the block on
veut tout bloquer mais en fait ça crée
un certain nombre des réactions de
pouvoir accepter justement le fait que
l'assemblée nationale vote à certain
nombre de textes présentés par la
majorité présidentielle c'est important
cette ouverture de monsieur haut doubs
là à la macro ni puisque sur le fond
vous donner l'accord vous êtes tous les
deux des représentants de formations
politiques qui sont contre
l'augmentation du smic vous êtes tous
les deux des représentants match ils
sont contre la retraite à 60 ans que
vous conte vers nous aujourd'hui et nous
préparions mardi une série de mesures
vous avez repéré au temps des paires
sociaux mais les français savent ou qui
a seule et véritable nation c'est vanier
au régime de mac vous êtes con de la
radio nationale mathurin mais nous on se
prépare à elle ou un rôle de femme nous
monsieur d'avancé nous sommes dans
l'opposition nous sommes pas dans la
même émission comme aux passionnés de
nive arranger alors justement vous êtes
le constitutionnaliste de ce plateau
voyais bien que on pas pour une des
coalitions à l'allemande est ce que la
france est prête elle ne l'est
évidemment pas déjà devant la presse les
français sont prêts pour ça et bien
double mais les partis politiques ont
voulu faire manifestement les français
c'est de ne pas donner à monsieur macron
une majorité absolue c'est de montrer
que le fait majoritaire n'est pas
inscrit dans la constitution donc ils
ont ouvert le jeu ensuite il ya des
options l'union nationale j'ai du mal à
la comprendre comme option en france on
fait d union nationale quand il ya des
guerres et quand les partis ont explosé
c'est pas le cas et manifestants 45 par
exemple oui
mais c'est pas le cas on voit ici que
les oppositions veulent être des
oppositions c'est leur travail la
seconde option c'est de faire des
coalitions effectivement la france n'a
pas cette culture j'ajouterai même et
c'est pas de la polémique politique
parce que je suis pas un homme politique
monsieur macro on n'a pas cette culture
il n'a pas la culture des coalitions il
a eu l'habitude de gouverner seul avec
une majorité qui était toujours acquise
à ses projets désormais il est obligé
que ça change la vie station à l'elysée
des responsables politiques en est on
est les textes
il reste des marges c'est-à-dire que je
serai pas complètement étonné non plus
qui est déjà en de l air qui est la
tentation de soutenir voire de partir
directement ce qu'a fait monsieur macron
c'est de faire exploser les partis de
gouvernement d'avant c'est à dire les
socialistes et les verts ça il a assez
bien réussi maintenant ça se retourne
contre lui parce qu'il ya une
polarisation de la politique à des gens
plus à gauche est plus à droite pour
dire les choses simplement qu'ils ne
veulent pas le soutenir qui veulent
s'opposer à lui parce qu'ils ont des
programmes différents désormais il
appartient à monsieur macron à sa
première ministre et à son gouvernement
de trouver ces majorités j'ajouterai
simplement une chose c'est qu'à mon sens
est passé par un jugement nous le mans
sur la personne je pense que c'était un
peu prématuré nommé madame baume pas
venir ministre avait avant les élections
législatives alors j'espère vraiment
qu'on va parler d'elisabeth borne à ce
qu'elle devrait rester à son poste ou
pas voici en tout cas ce qu'on pense
françois bayrou c'était ce matin chez
nos confrères de france inter on écoute
je pense que les temps exige que le
premier ministre sous la première mini
soit politique qu'on n'ait pas le
sentiment que c'est la technique qui
gouverne le pays mais au contraire les
sentiments profonds qui s'exprime dans
le peuple mohamed là qu'il avoue qui est
député modem vous êtes d'accord avec
françois bayrou écoutez c'est le choix
d'ailleurs du président de la république
a dit vous vous en pensez quoi je pense
effectivement
le logiciel tel que nous l'avons connue
sur le dernier mandat n'existe plus donc
il va falloir repartir du 2 elle
représente l'avant et hip hop il va
falloir partir d'une feuille blanche à
savoir effectivement tenir compte de
l'expression des français aujourd'hui et
les français nous disent quoi ils nous
disent on veut participer et c'est pour
ça qu'on retrouve des groupes où c'est
important ça soit le rassemblement
national où que ce soit la france est
soumise du ps d'une façon globale mais à
falloir tenir compte de l'expression des
français or les français veulent pas de
chaos surtout ils veulent pas comble il
symbolise pas le chaos si non on veut
pas mais la fille c'est tout cas le
social quand vous voyez la position de
la france est soumise
on les entend on vienne pour tout
bloquer pour tout ça les français n'en
veulent pas ils veulent surtout qu'on
trouve des solutions et des solutions à
leurs problèmes et dans l'urgence donc
on verra le comportement des députés
d'un côté comme de l'eau ça sera pas le
parti politique mais l'ibère borg est
justement être la personne qui pourra
trouver des compromis politiques
c'est ce que dit françois bayrou a
écouté qu'il sous-entend moi je pense
que c'est une c'est une femme d'abord de
valeur que c'était une excellente
ministre qui a porté des réformes très
dur mais de donner à dieu qui a donné à
gérer tournage contre les choix oui là
tu as de l'argent de chômage l'arrêt du
sien c'est très dur effectivement ça que
ça dure donc c'est une femme de
courageuses et aujourd'hui elle est
allée elle a remis sa démission donc en
latéraux conduite on verra ce que dira
le président ce soir je vous attendais
je pense pas qu'ils manquent
mélenchon compromis soient gênés
redoules vous attendez à ce qu'il ait
effectivement s'exprime sur la première
ministre ce soir emmanuel macron mais
dans le régime dans lequel nous sommes
même et a fortiori avec emmanuel macron
c'est pas un problème de premier
ministre la personne de madame bornes
finalement importe peu même si elle est
teintée d'un bilan qui aujourd'hui est
rejetée par des millions de français qui
étaient quand même d'une violence rare
les français une violence anti sociale
hallucinant l'idée sont que ce soit la
réforme de l'assurance chômage que ce
soit la casse d'une clé à français que
ce soit l'expulsion des 15000 soignants
qui n'ont pas fait trop de la
vaccination tout ça c'est des mesures
comme qui symboliquement son heure tente
pour des millions de français donc c'est
un symbole de la garder mais très
sincèrement il peut mettre pierre paul
ou jacques si monsieur macron poursuit
avec cette ligne ultralibérale cette
ligne anti sociales qui sont derrière
cela normal effectivement ça ne changera
rien les braves d'olive et jacques blanc
nous appelons nom ne lie to fade les
lauréats plomb un changement de braquet
nous appelons à ce que monsieur mac on
ouvre les yeux sur la réalité politique
et sociale de notre pays est très
clairement une réalité qui s'impose à
lui donc il faut changer de politique
paul veyne il ya déjà une motion de
censure en préparation du côté de l efym
semble-t-il parce qu'elle va faire un
discours fin normalement le 5 juillet le
discours de politique générale prévu
pour l'instant le 5 juillet motion de
censure donc vous en faites vous pensez
qu'elle devrait quitter son poste au
sein de votre parti chaque chose en son
temps on nous accuse de semer le
désordre en l'occurrence l'ordre ou la
caquerelle me semble-t-il usage prévoit
qu'à la conclusion d'un discours de
politique générale le gouvernement on
demande la confiance de l'assemblée
manifestement dans ce moment difficile
pour la majorité dans la recherche d'une
combinaison avec la droite peut-être
avec l'extrême droite il se pourrait que
madame bord ne demande pas de vote de
confiance alors nous verrons parce que
oui elle doit se présenter face aux
représentants du peuple français et sa
légitimité ne peut pas venir uniquement
de la tête de l'exécutif du président de
la république oui il y à une crise
institutionnelle mais paradoxalement la
match si la règle relative maison une
majorité tout ne confirmait pas mais
alors pas vous allez qu'ils assument de
la vérifier si elle existe cette
majorité et que madame byrne demande
lors de l'assemblée et là nous verrons
nous verrons si elle l'obtient si elle
ne l'obtient pas elle devra partir comme
d'ailleurs elle aurait dû le faire eu
égard à la claque à la déroute que les
électeurs ont infligé à ce gouvernement
qui a annoncé une politique anti sociale
dans les quelques semaines de
l'interlude qu'il a exercé vous
réagissez oui on voit un peu les excès
de langage d'un côté comme de l'autre le
président de la république était réélu
mélenchon finit 3e battue sectionnelles
pour se débarrasser du plein d'âme le
crès nous avaient battus pour la
deuxième des fonds donc les inondations
d'humanité c'est évident ils ont validé
son programme et non hélas ma
progression après les élèves il a eu le
courage de mettre sur la table y compris
la réforme des retraites dont il a été
la seule chose est de présenter hélas
été élu et je vous le rappelle quand
même parce que tu as l'impression
qu'elle avait perdue ensuite il apparaît
valence et noir faire les français argué
que de nos jours sans indiquer dans quel
ministère par une araignée or d'ensemble
certes on n'a pas la majorité absolue
mais on a on est quand même plus
nombreux donc on verra aujourd'hui votre
comportement surtout vis-à-vis des
français c'est ce que j'attends donc à
la prochaine loi de finances ça va
arriver très vite dès début juillet on
verra votre comportement est ce qu'il
sera est-ce qu'il ira dans le bon sens
c'est à dire en faveur des français qui
en ont besoin et qu'ils ont besoin de ça
très vite ou alors vous allez les 50
flérien qu'ont les français au nord de
100 cède 13 points de chômage je suis
désolé c'est 5 sur le b dans le pilat il
a été validé par les français je
n'arrivais pas été
les différents projets avancent
ajustements denis baron j'ai parlé un
peu de droit constitutionnel
effectivement elisabeth bande a présenté
sa démission à emmanuel macron qu'il a
refusé en fait lui peut la garder au il
peut en changer comment ça se passe d'un
point de vue constitutionnel c'est le
président qui nomme large première
ministre et là il n'est pas élu je me
rappelle il pourrait bien devoir
démissionner mais elle pourrait ça
pourrait être une députée en tout cas il
n'y a pas de pratiques de l'investiture
sous la vème république c'est à dire que
normalement il n'ya pas pratiqué c'est
pas dans le texte mais qu'il n'y a pas
besoin de demander la confiance
maintenant il ya une chose importante a
rappelé et ce n'est pas donc comme en
allemagne où le chancelier l'aurait
chance elle est l'émanation de
l'assemblée dans un régime parlementaire
si je puis dire il ya un procédé électif
ses terres en gros le premier ministre
c'est le chef du parti majoritaire et en
allemagne à une élection au sens propre
du terme mais je voudrais rappeler une
chose c'est que même si madame bornes ne
demandait pas la confiance la confiance
s'est pas seulement les questions de
confiance ou les motions de censure
négativement c'est sur chaque loi c'est
sur la prochaine loi de finances c'est à
chaque discussion et la perte de
confiance elle se manifestera dans la
vie quotidienne de l'assemblée nationale
nous que madame bornes la demande non en
régime parlementaire elle en aura besoin
si elle pourra utiliser le 49-3 donc
c'est pour les aviser les toits une fois
par session avait quand même le risque
énorme d'une motion de censure je pense
que les oppositions
n'hésiteront pas trop à se coaliser
contre elle c'est à dire qu'en gros le
49-3 ils étaient en partie désactivé en
2008 si on a un pas exactement par
session mais un texte par session et
ensuite il peut toujours aller voir une
motion de censure elle pourrait bien
arriver ça va être compliqué en tout cas
on le sait on va écouter tout de suite
marine le pen c'était aujourd'hui
justement à l'occasion de la venue des
premiers députés enfin des députés du
rassemblement national à l'assemblée une
séquence
voilà importante il ya eu également
l'élection de chef de groupe à
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui aurore
bergé qui a été élu à la tête des
députés la république en marche olivier
marleix qu ce qui devient chef lr on
écoute marine le pen
imaginez que c'est en même temps
l'émotion et la fierté que je ressens ce
matin mais c'est aussi
je pense aussi à tous nos électeurs je
pense à ces millions de français qui
sont privés d'une représentation juste à
l'assemblée nationale depuis pour
certains des décennies et qui ce matin
enfin je crois se sentent représentés
alors il reste le perchoir bien sûr ça
sera dans quelques jours un poste
extrêmement important et puis à la
présidence de la commission des finances
on va y revenir mohamed l aquila gérard
larcher a dit que la présidence de la
commission des finances devait revenir
justement à marine le pen qu'est ce que
vous en pensez m
j'ai participé à la présidence en tout
cas l'élection sur le dernier mandat de
d'eric woerth la majorité ne vote pas
savoir que la majorité ne s'exprime pas
en tout cas de façon traditionnelle
laisse tout ça au maine de l'opposition
dont qu'il présente auront probablement
des candidats et puis eux veulent dire
ça se passe entre eux en gros la
majorité ne participent pas au vote ça
se passe en temps dans votre avis
justement peut le gagner marine le pen
qui prendra la présidence de la
commission je ne crois pas des finances
sauf si en effet l'usagé été rompu par
la majorité mais j'entends ce que dit
monsieur a priori il a doublé le souhait
rien c'est parce que j'ai une vision
bien là entre rassemblant nationale
pétition puisqu'il ya 150 députés de la
nuque puis 89 du rassemblement national
le démarrer le des rats est hélas les
républicains nous aurons une candidature
unique pour présenter une proposition à
là pour prendre la présidence en 2000 au
swing qui représentera la constituent et
qui représentera la nuque et sauf si la
majorité relative actuelle venait
perturber le fonctionnement habituel de
l'assemblée nationale en ne respectant
pas l'usagé bien cette présidence
reviendra à la nuque comme ce que la
famille
j'explique aux téléspectateurs la france
a soumise à moins de députés que
rassemblements nationalistes ont
d'ailleurs je vous rappelle il ya des
groupes ne sont pas encore constitués
que nous sommes en discussion par
exemple avec des députés ultramarins
donc y compris ce point
encore conclu et je le redis nous avons
nous fait élire près de 150 députés dans
le cadre d'une alliance construite
autour d'un programme partagé de 650
mesure il y a presque deux fois plus de
députés de la nuque que du rassemblement
national à ce que vous souhaitiez vous
souhaiteriez avoir se passe évidemment
mouvement ça y est ils ce sont les
français qui ont ils ont désigné comme
première opposition elle nous revient
cette présidence généraux dole sauf que
la différence entre le rassemblement
national et l'extrême gauche c'est que
l'extrême gauche est divisée divisée
entre quatre formations politiques est
divisée d'un point de vue politique avec
des divergences profondes sur des sujets
et d'ailleurs il ya déjà du rififi dans
cette alliance puisque même au sein de
la france insoumise on en vient à
critiquer le grand timonier monsieur
mélenchon il ya divergence chez les
écologistes qui n'ont même pas réussi à
constituer un parti un groupe politique
nuxe et donc ils restent divisés donc ça
va être très compliqué pour eux de
désigner un seul candidat pour la
commission des finances ne nous avons la
cohérence et nous avons nous avons la
cohérence nous avons la solidité nous
sommes unis et nous sommes le premier
groupe d'opposition donc de par cette
réalité nous avons vocation à présider
la commission des finances le pas
tradition républicaine nous nous ce que
nous exigeons c'est simple la démocratie
tout la démocratie rien la démocratie
nous ne sommes pas des élus au rabais
nous avons été élus par des citoyens
français ils nous ont placés comme
première opposition à monsieur macro
dont acte et donc il faut qu'on ait la
plénitude des moyens des pouvoirs d'une
véritable opposition de leurs six
premières oppositions mais bon on ne
sait pas en tout cas quand nous mais
mais ce sont des artifices et annonça
vraiment il dit selon la mairie la
verrez vous verrez donc on va dire que
jour ce moment c'est la macro ni qui par
son par sa position tranchera cette
question ou bien elle respecte en effet
le choix des électeurs qui ont désigné
une première opposition de façon très
nette c'est la nuque ou bien dans une
forme de combines pour peut-être répond
je vous dis aux interruptions de
l'extrême un drap elle fera basculer
cette décision mais là mercredi qu'il va
baisser les stations françaises soumises
et la faire à l'envers puisque le
puisque jauzion est de savoir si en
effet je suis juste à glisser
moi commission du final est élu j'ai vu
comment ça s'est passé six ans à
s'élancer il ya cinq ans c'est
exactement comme cela que ça s'est passé
dire que la majorité ne s'est pas
exprimée dans vos rangs certains
voudraient peut-être ferait le contraire
alors ça sera le cas également au banc
ça sera le cas exactement eh bien c'est
une bonne nouvelle elle est très
respectueuse de la conclusion deux étés
j'attire juste l'attention en cas même
sur le rôle du président de la
commission finance
un rôle important et notamment en
matière de secret fiscal avec le
président il a accès à bercy à des des
dossiers de sociétés donc dont le secret
fiscal doit être gardée et donc voilà
donc je je je je je dis cela tout
simplement part à ce par rapport à ceux
qui ne respecteraient pas les
institutions denis baron gérard
justement si on garde le droit est ce
que c'est une tradition je veux dire
qu'il n'est pas écrite que ça soit
l'opposition qui s'occupe de voter de
désigner cette présidence de la
commission des finances est ce que comme
dit paul vannier et bien par exemple
s'il avait le crâne la macro ni des
sites cette fois que milan soit pas que
ça soit pas le cas il ya ce soit eux qui
décident oui c'est une pratique sur deux
conventions de la constitution si vous
voulez dans un but d'apaisement
[Musique]
l'opposition doit être une opposition
responsable elle doit avoir accès à une
partie des responsabilités ça a été
l'esprit de cette évolution ça s'est
bien passé si je puis dire jusqu'à
maintenant d'ailleurs il ya maintenant
c'est exact un certain nombre de députés
de la majorité relative qui ont dit que
ça pourrait changer ça va être
intéressant pour le constitutionnaliste
que je suis après les oppositions se
dénombrent hommes
mais ça peut tout à fait changer en fait
cela ce n'est pas
le risque de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
tout de même c'est la paralysie c'est ça
le risque c'est un risque parce qu'on
n'a pas une culture de travail
parlementaire mais sur cette base là moi
le risque je le vois pas la paralysie ça
voudra dire que le gouvernement veut
continuer à gouverner selon les
pratiques habituelles de la vème
république hors cohabitation et que les
oppositions n'arrive pas à travailler
avec lui mais c'est un risque à mon avis
potentiels se seraient de la
responsabilité de tout le monde à
l'assemblée nationale et au gouvernent
mon psy la france n'étaient pas
gouvernés l'idée que la france est
ingouvernable paraît fausse elle est
tout à fait gouvernable
institutionnellement parce qu'un régime
parlementaire c'est flexible donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut que les partis
soient responsables c'est ça la
vérité doivent être responsables c'est
les députés qui dois je rappeler tout à
l'heure c'est éthique de comportement et
de responsabilité donc sur chaque texte
sur chaque amendement
on doit tous interrogés et faire preuve
d'intelligence au au service des
français parce que les français ne nous
demande pas de bloquer le pays mais les
oppositions co2 ou manger si vous voulez
d'agir et d'agir très vite les
onéreuses et oui mais alors si on en
revient au texte lorsque justement on
n'est pas d'accord sur les programmes
par exemple ce propos il va y avoir ce
projet de loi d'abord sur le pouvoir
d'achat c'est sûr vous bouldou finances
rectificative y aura probablement un
texte qui va dans le bon sens en tout
cas pour répondre aux exigences et et
dont voici qui serait en fait
susceptible de le voter alors
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas
d'augmentation du smic par exemple que
défend la nuque il n'ya pas non plus de
baisse de tva que défend le rn il se
rapprocherait plutôt d'un programme lr
or les élèves ont dit que ce
manifestement c'est du cas par cas
donkey le vôtre a écouté il y aura un
amendement par amendement d'abord en
commissions de travail en commission qui
est beaucoup plus important pour moi que
celui où on a un petit peu le théâtre
dans les pouilles ajouté hausse durable
des uns et des autres il va falloir
apprendre à travailler différemment par
rapport effectivement au dernier mandat
où il y avait une majorité absolue donc
faire preuve d'intelligence et
travailler avant d'en parham en ont
toujours dans le bon ça te voir comment
répondre effectivement aux français
aujourd'hui qui attendent des réponses
ils n'attendent pas qu'on bloque le
système paul gagné vous voyez travailler
comme ça en tout cas l apprendre à
travailler différemment je crois que ça
vaut pour la majorité puisque dans la
précédente législature et député de la
france insoumise ont déposé des milliers
voire des dizaines de milliers de noms
parler d'obstruction
chez moi ces obstructions et à quel
moment c'est constructif 0,1 pour cent
des amendements que nous avons des étés
que nous avons déposé ces cinq dernières
années ont été acceptées par
le pouvoir mc rogne 1 et donc je vous
retourne la question quand nous allons
par amendement le smig on regarde 500
euros qui est une une solution d'urgence
vitale vous regarderez problèmes des
français je vous le dit monsieur vous le
savez sans doute des millions de
personnes sont en train de sombrer en ce
moment même dans une pauvreté noire des
gens fin dans ce pays ils sont pris à la
gorge par l'envolée des prix
alimentaires le paquet et pierre arcens
où nous sommes moins commises sur le
comment vous allez hop le smic à 1500
euros elle aurait à répondre à l' effet
à cette proposition et dont vous je vous
retourne je voulais me semble que la
question de l'arrêt à nice allait
examiner le texte dans votre gros
boussinot amont en commission un
amendement par amendement je rappelle
que simplement le par rapport au mandat
qui vient de se passer il est arrivé que
des collègues de chez nous de notre
majorité travaille aussi avec des vous
avez jeunes bon sens le point d'indicé
le smic pendant cinq ans
indice de la gravité de la situation
actuelle a déjà fait en juillet si vous
allez suivre en tout cas si vous aussi
vous faites preuve de responsabilité
mais c'est bien et c'est le smic à 1500
euros c'est une mesure d'urgence vient
vous déposerez un amendement dans ce
sens et vous que feriez vous s'ils
étaient des vous et que vous déposez
attendait 600 qui sera discutée une
série sur un débattu en commission
c'était génial bonne ou contre le 1500
une façon selon ce débat là on l'aura
dans l'hémicycle et on ira d'avancé sur
gildas est manifestement ce n'est pas en
prendre la majorité tout de même
pardonné
d'alimentation des années le pouvoir
parlementaire effectivement il est
peut-être temps j'ai tant mieux parce
que les français c'est ce qu'une 10
aujourd'hui genious il faut que ça se
passe au parloir la baisse de la tva par
exemple ça c'est un des projets
effectivement rassemblement national il
n'est pas je reviens encore là dessus il
n'est pas dans le projet du pouvoir
d'achat du gouvernement non ça fait près
dé vous pourriez vous que marine le pen
demande cette baisse de tva pour rendre
150 euros à 200 euros de pouvoir d'achat
par mois à chaque ménage à chaque fois
la macro ni à balayer cette balayer d'un
revers de ce que vous pourriez votée par
les caisses que ce que je veux dire ce
projet dans la bouche des députés macro
nist il parle de responsabilité
en fait on entend derrière soumission
c'est qu'ils ne veulent pas d'opposition
ils ne veulent pas de divergence enel
maquereau en fait à un problème que
j'allais dire symptomatique un problème
viscéral avec toute forme d'opposition
de contestation sans pouvoir la cession
de six sur sept est sûr j'avais sur ward
algérois nous regarde bon évidemment
article par article nous attendrons
évidemment parce que nous travaillons
nous sommes sérieux nous sommes
responsables nous ce qui nous importe
c'est améliorer votre sort
excusez moi moi je suis pas dans des
biens
gauchistes qui consiste en fait sur les
rotations du solo de vouloir tout faire
exploser des entreprises moi je dis donc
c'est concret je suis dans le conteneur
et voilà c'est donc moi je suis dans le
pays et les elle montre les années
passent mais c'est pas ça le pays réel
le pays reste c'est la baisse de la tva
de la transparence
oui on est très clair et nous on
demandera j'aime on demande retombé par
une demandera au gouvernement on
demandera la majorité de se positionner
sur ces baisses de tva sur les produits
premiers l'augmentation du smic ce que
disent ils au mans sur une fois ci nous
rejoignent si à un moment donné il ya un
éclair de lucidité évidemment que nous
soutiendrons c'est donc vous pouvez
réagir - mettez clés à ce que vient de
dire julien odoul donc vous accepterez
toutes les voix quel que soit le parti
pouvait pas empêcher un déporté de voter
sur un texte sur un amendement va pas
lui dire vous êtes d'accord à clous mais
surtout ne votez pas pour ce cet
amendement à ce texte ces autres sujets
et à la liberté quand même de vote du
député avant tout la autres sujets bien
sûr c'est la retraite parce que là
effectivement les clivages sont
extrêmement importants mohamed l aquila
comment faire passer la réforme de la
retraite aujourd'hui avec l'assemblée
nationale comme elle est aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup plus urgent que
ce sujet ben oui ça commandé de telles
injections commencent à donner de ma
main a dit brunet plus badin excusez moi
on est plus en campagne et le pot le
projet de la retraite il est prévu pour
la fin 2023 d'après les registres 8
s'est tout de suite maintenant on va
s'en dire des plus aux députés chers
collègues donc le premier texte qui va
nous être présenté ce sera la loi de
finances rectificative
répondre très vite ce sera le mois de
juillet probablement début mai sur la
retraite sur la retraite une avocate il
va y avoir aimé la conscience a su
anciens s'est pas rendu il va falloir
prendre le temps de le consulter et avec
la nouvelle configuration qui est on
aujourd'hui qu'elle a aujourd'hui donc
il y aura cette consultation et puis on
travaillera sur le texte en
retraite à 65 ans bonjour du roi
aujourd'hui l'âge moyen de départ à la
retraite 64 ans et quelque 67 18 ans
fils donc voilà donc enfin macron
c'était 65 peut-être 64 mo et justement
j'imagine paul vannier vous vous êtes
toujours sur la retraite à 60 ans c'est
d'ailleurs vous aussi oui pour ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler tout à fait
donc 61 la justice la santé social mais
pourquoi parce que nous nous moi je
pense aux millions de personnes qui ont
58 59 ans et qui ont vu cette
possibilité de partir à la retraite à 60
ans à taux plein leur échapper avec
cette élection présidentielle ce second
tour imposé entre marine le pen et melle
mâcon qui je le répète ni l'un ni
l'autre ne défendent cette proposition
quand vous leur proposez c'est les
médias qui ont décidé les valises de
retraite à 60 ans parce que nous savons
la finance et il a encore chacun sera au
rendez vous des responsabilités nous la
proposerons par abonnement avec un
travail en effet c'est sérieux est sûre
le d'âge mais c'est une réponse encore
une fois à la situation extrêmement
difficile que vivent les français les
gens sont épuisés par le travail il faut
donner ce droit où va qui ont mélangé
devrait en bonne santé la mission de
monsieur déjà prises nous avons
l'honneur d'être élu de la république ce
n'est pas un travail nous ne sommes pas
forcés mais ça veut dire quoi qui n'a
jamais travaillé ni seront pas forcés
d'être là elle s'est engagée comme vous
comme moi ça n'est pas un travail nous
n'avons pas un contrat de travail qui
nous lie à un employeur nous n'avons pas
un rapport de subordination à un
employeur nous ne vivons pas vous et moi
les
bâtiments la chaîne a
présenté par donc dans le projet des
manuels macron ça vous ne votez pas
d'entraînement et le jeune julien odoul
non plus certainement pas et on a fait
encore le texte qu'avez-vous d'entrée de
jeu à dire ce texte sur le rejette parce
qu'ils aiment
c'est un total n'y a pas besoin d'avoir
le texte pour avoir la garde de sophie
de ce texte va te lèves de monsieur mari
un peu plus haut sauf si effectivement
il tient compte du résultat et il ya une
inflexion moi je pense qu'il serait de
bon ton je pense qu'il serait
responsable de sa part compte tenu du
résultat des législatives d'arrêter
d'abandonner cette réforme qui t'arrange
mare socialiste veut pas commenter un
texte qu'on n'a pas entre les mains il
faut laisser ça vous en connaissez les
grandes lignes a tout de même les grands
les merile attendons qu'il soit écrit il
sans philosophie en l'occurrence en fait
tel convoi le plein tout pardonner -
denis baranger quand on parle de
paralysie c'est quand même ou peut-être
immobilisme ou en tout cas à minima
c'est un peu ça qu'on voit peut-être se
dégager
on voit se dégager une vie
institutionnelle qui promet d'être
intéressante mais en train de le mée
alors intéressante ça veut dire pas
efficace forcément non non ça je suis
pas d'accord avec ça quand il y à débat
quand il y as conflit politique quand il
ya des désaccords quand la france est
mieux représentés à l'assemblée
nationale avec cette chance que ce soit
à l'intérieur de l'assemblée nationale
qu'il y eu une discussion qui peut être
un conflit politique parce qu'il ya des
désaccords c'est mieux que quand il ya
des crises sociales qu'il est allé gilet
jaune et qu'il y à des conflits qui sont
dans la rue aujourd'hui on a une
assemblée nationale qui représente mieux
la france ce plateau on est
l'illustration moi je peux pas m'en
plaindre et la thèse de
l'ingouvernabilité je la partage pas
alors on attend bien sûr ce discours d'
emmanuel macron qui va avoir lieu à 20h
heure française donc c'est dans un peu
moins de dix minutes le chef de l'état
qui donc va prononcer cette allocution
c'est la première fois qu'il prend la
parole donc depuis cet échec de post
élections législatives il va peut-être
expliquer la manière dont il va
gouverner encore une fois un mois mais
de là qu'il a j'ai envie de revenir un
peu sur ma première question justement
pour qu'on comprenne bien ce qu'on
attend de cette allocution des macros
déjà autour de ce plateau il manque
quand même pas mal d'acteurs bien serré
c'est c'est aussi les écolos c'est aussi
le parti communiste le parti socialiste
c'est les républicains donc voir un
petit peu c'est ça ça va être ça le
débat cette résidence est plutôt basse
et les coalitions désaccord sur sade
écoutant effectivement le mes deux
collègues c'est ce sera certainement pas
avec la français subissent ou le
rassemblement national vont en discuter
au nom mais il ya une illusion d'unités
du côté de chez ensemble on comprendra
que monsieur edouard philippe a un
agenda qu'il l'a d'ailleurs engagé et
qu'il va je crois contredire souvent le
président de la réplique par exemple
lorsque lui défend la retraite à 67 ans
c'est ce qu'il a proposé quand il défend
la réduction du déficit public monsieur
macron dans la campagne présidentielle a
annoncé son intention de le diminuer de
80 milliards d'euros sur le quinquennat
80 milliards d'euros c'est l'équivalent
du budget de l'éducation nationale et de
ministères de l'intérieur de la police
alors je vous pose une question et ce
sera le débat qui traversera le groupe
ensemble où allez vous coupez allez vous
supprimez des soignants allez vous
supprimez des enseignants allez vous
supprimez dépolitiser le débat réduire
la dépense de 80 milliards d'euros vous
allez devoir leurs chers collègues je ne
sais pas si vous aller siéger à la
commission finances ce que ça va être
très vite c'est mon premier mandat mais
il va y avoir justement il va y avoir le
débat là dessus les français il va
falloir répondre très vite je vous pose
la question rom au sein du crime la
prima kron qui va être doublée est-ce
que vous avez la voter pareil dans les
80 milliards et
vous faire est ce que vous allez faire
comment allez-vous vous avez des tas
d'histoires de vous la dynamique vous
avez coupé où il va y avoir devrait
avoir arbitrage de dépenses publiques
manifestement c'est une ligne rouge
d'après ce qu'on a entendu
dire excusez moi on a vu quand même le
bilan même si vous le contester c'est
votre droit on l'a vu ce bilan
aujourd'hui en baissant les impôts en
baissant les taxes et notamment les
taxes sur sur la production les
entreprises aujourd'hui parmi ses fans
le chômage le chômage a baissé la cftc
fo la flotte trois gars
elle a donné des recettes à la de donner
davantage de 16,5 milliards d'euros
sur les finances publiques par exemple
avec des personnalités du parti
socialiste d'europe écologie les verts
et l air et non effectivement sur les
finances publiques cette question-là pas
forcément le même avis vous savez ça va
être compliqué
on discutera texte par tex a écrit en
double en duel et vous serez dépendant
d'un petit parti un petit parti qui a
quand même bon combien responsa combien
d'élus une question de sur twitter en
tout cas de kiel oscars les
personnalités politiques ont elles pris
conscience de la rupture de confiance
avec le peuple voilà une question donc
de sur twitter donc dans nos
téléspectateurs est ce que vous pouvez
répondre peut-être julien odoul les
personnalités pas tout en tout cas
je sais pas s'il ya une rupture de
confiance avec le peuple c'est ce que
oui
parce que là effectivement on se
félicite qu'une finalement une dose de
proportionnelle se soient finalement
imposée d'un sommet national mais il
faut pas oublier qu'un électeur sur deux
qui ne s'est pas déplacé et un électeur
sur deux aujourd'hui qui est en marge de
la république en marge de nos
institutions il considère que la
politique ne sert à rien c'est ça la
réalité et il ya une prise de conscience
et il faut que ces prises de grandes
choses et c'est pour ça que nous nous
appelons un choc démocratique avec le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne pour
permettre aux citoyens de retrouver la
parole retrouvée l'action publique et
aussi la proportionnelle parce que je
pense qu'on n'en passera que par là pour
renouer le lien qui s'est distendu avec
des promesses qu'ils ont été trahis et
surtout avec une pratique du pouvoir
notamment de monsieur macro extrêmement
solitaire voire autoritaire paul veyne
hier pour répondre à cette question de
notre téléspectateurs sur twitter et
personnalités politiques ont elles pris
conscience de la rupture de confiance
avec le peuple nous ne nous en avons
pleinement conscience nous pensons nous
depuis plusieurs années que la vème
république agonise nous vivons une très
grave crise démocratique l'abstention
elle est encore à un niveau historique
lors de ses derniers rendez-vous en est
la principale manifestation et même
maquereau en est le responsable il a
mené une campagne en fuyant le débat on
ne voulant pas présenté son programme ou
alors quelques mesures uniquement en
refusant les débats il a aggravé cette
situation nous proposons nous le passage
à une sixième république de convoquer
une assemblée constituante pour que les
français refondre leur régime on voit
qu'il ya un débat régime présidentiel
régime parlementaire aux français de
trancher les institutions leur
appartienne mohamed equilar avant la
prise par
revenir un petit peu un actionnaire ans
et ils ont tranché effectivement ils ont
dit aujourd'hui on veut que ça change on
veut que tout change et je crois qu'il
va falloir comme pour se posent la
question en tant qu'élu en tant que
député aujourd'hui va falloir qu'on
revoit notre logiciel qu'on fasse un
reset sur le passé et qu'on se remette
avec une certaine intelligence
effectivement à essayer de trouver des
solutions mais des solutions pour les
français et pas simplement pour un camp
contre l'autre et arrêter cette ré
essayé de réconcilier les français avec
la politique avant denis ben justement
sur le si une réforme constitutionnelle
demande de tiers de compliquer enfin
c'est il faut une grosse majorité qui va
bien au delà de la majorité absolue
très simple sauf le système
proportionnel qu'on peut mettre avec
peut-être comme ça c'est ça c'est des
lois ordinaires ça c'est des lois
ordinaires mais en pour modifier la
constitution et ça m'étonnerait ça
m'étonnerait même que son conseil
national de la refondation
existe désormais désormais le conseil
national de la fondation c'est le
parlement lui-même le président devra
apprendre à travailler avec le parlement
point il n'y a pas de relégation dans la
liste je suis content de faire sur ce
bateau le fait qu'il faudra travailler
ensemble au sein du par l'onu mais c'est
quelque chose dont on est d'accord c'est
quelque chose d'inédit quand même donc
qu'il va falloir essayer de travailler
end une intelligemment au niveau du
parlement et je dis bien un texte par
sinon dissolution est visible ça c'est
alors aux agressions constitutionnel et
peut-être si vraiment on est bien dès
qu'il y aura un ou une présidente de
l'assemblée nationale pour être consulté
à cette fin le président pourra
dissoudre c'est à dire le 28 il le fera
probablement pas elle mais il peut et
parce qu'à un risque énorme mais
techniquement il le peut absolument quoi
que disent certaines de nos instituts
voilà on attend vraiment d'une minute à
l'autre emmanuel macron qui va donc
s'exprimer en direct de l'elysée pour la
première fois depuis justement les
résultats de ces élections législatives
merci d'être d'être avec nous tous merci
de nous suivre sur france 24 puisqu'on
va suivre bien sûr cette allocution en
direct de l'elysée sur france 24 vous
merci à tous